[Music]
seven kingdoms is a single realm
made up of seven realms that once were
independent kings landing it's the
capital city of this world
it is a place where there is
extravagance and wealth
and decadence lannisters are the
wealthiest family in westeros and have
been for centuries
each of the houses has their heroic
symbol for the lannisters it's a lion
red is the lannister color cersei
lannister is the queen
she was married to the king and
essentially an arranged marriage in
order to keep the kingdoms together
after rebellion it's not a damn
joust before i pissed myself i believe
that cersei really loved robert in the
beginning and thought
that they could make it work but you
know on their wedding night he calls out
another name from then on
i think she's pretty wounded she's very
politically minded
and very aware of power
for her the the highest morality is
protect the family
someday you'll sit on the throne and the
truth will be what you make it
jamie her twin brother is one of the
members of the kingsguard
an elite order of knights their duty is
to
guard the king at all times jamie is
called the king slayer
because he was actually previously a
member of kingsguard for the last
targaryen king
and he actually killed the king that he
had sworn to protect
what did the mad king say when you
stabbed him in the back
he is considered not quite trustworthy
cersei and jaime the twins have another
brother
tyrion lannister tyrion is a dwarf he's
younger than his two siblings he enjoys
playing with people's expectations of
him he's had a very complicated
upbringing
in relation to his father being a dwarf
and all that that's in the medieval
times that was considered
a judgment of the gods word's probably
gotten to my father by now
he'll be offering a handsome reward
everyone knows
lannister always pays his debts it's
just a little
reminder to the people in this world who
are constantly stabbing each other in
the back that if you scratch my back i
will scratch yours
[Music]
on the far western coast of the
continent high atop a rocky promontory
overlooking the sunset sea
sits casterly rock ancestral seat
of house lannister below it lies lannis
port one of the great cities of westeros
a center for trade culture and the great
lannister fleet
there are a number of gold and silver
mines in the westerlands
making it the richest region in all of
westeros
one of the most productive mines lies
beneath casterly rock itself
making house lannister the wealthiest of
all the noble houses
this allows house lannister to finance
many endeavors of other noble houses
even the king himself has sought credit
from casterly rock from time to time
we lannisters claim our descent from the
andal invaders
and through the female bloodline land
the clever
according to the legend lan using only
his wits
one casterly rock from the noble house
of casterly
during the age of heroes the lannisters
reigned as kings of the rock for
thousands of years
and worked to make it the envy of the
rest of the seven kingdoms
our time as kings ended however when
aegon targaryen
otherwise known as aegon the conqueror
arrived in westeros with his army
the last king of the rock king lauren
lannister
joined forces with king mern gardner the
king of the reach
together with sixty thousand men they
met the targaryen host in open battle
history tells us that aegon unleashed
all
three of his dragons slaughtering four
thousand men
at what came to be known as the field of
fire
kingman himself was burned alive that
day
and house gardener turned to ash with
him
seeing both the threat and opportunity
the targaryens represented lauren wisely
surrendered
and aided aegon in his further conquest
of westeros
the lannisters were thus appointed lords
paramount of the westerlands
and wardens of the west titles we hold
to this day let us be
clear though it is neither luck nor
royal
favor that makes our house prosperous
[Music]
there have been times in our history
where some have thought as
weak lazy or opulent
my father titus lannister nearly
bankrupted our house with his poor
investments
and allowed himself to be mocked openly
at court
when our vassal the reigns of castamere
dared to rise up against the lannisters
they learned how dangerous it can be to
taunt a lion
i tywin lannister led the assault on
castamere to put down this rebellion
i made an example of them to anyone who
doubts
our might they even made a quaint song
about the fates of the reigns of
castamere
sadly there are no reigns left to hear
it
today the golden lion of lannister is
rightly admired and
feared throughout the seven kingdoms
our words are hear me roar
but there are other words that should be
remembered when crossing a lion of
casterly rock
lannister always pays his debts